hey credit warriors welcome back to the
67th ever episode of the iced coffee
hour i'm the credit shifu aka ben and so
far this podcast has made 80
179
wow that was the best one yet i i don't
know man it wasn't that good are you
serious yeah
i'm gonna be and now i'm gonna be
completely honest jack wouldn't say that
wait a second so we have to address the
elephants in the room here
what happened to jack what did you just
call me
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
well then okay
jack unfortunately is not feeling well
he wasn't able to make it but
temporarily alex is going to be filling
in for this episode jack is going to be
back for all the remaining episodes but
we figured today we're going to have
alex on because it's a bonus episode
yeah this is a bonus exactly we got a
bonus episode out today and this is
really exciting because you don't know
alex is a huge fan of you no really whoa
whoa whoa
i wouldn't say huge
moderate astronomical
i do i do i do enjoy your videos yes and
this is a this is actually a really
special episode for me too because
you're the first person that we've had
on that's into the whole credit card
game into credit card churning getting
free stuff free rewards just basically
getting everything at no cost at the
expense of the credit cards and your
channel i've been watching for probably
three years i remember because a long
time ago there was this bonus on the ink
preferred yeah and i did a video about
it and you got it yes because and you
made a comment
that you got it and i was pleased cause
like you were the only person i'd heard
of who'd got it because you had to have
like a relationship manager or something
and uh so yeah that was really cool yes
that that's right so the story behind
that was uh i watch your videos almost
all of them and back then you had posted
this promotion i think it was a hundred
thousand points for the chase inc and
you had to go in person to the chase
bank and there was one like 50 feet away
from my office so i saw your video
immediately went down got the offer and
that was equivalent well at the minimum
that's worth like a thousand dollars
basically right yeah or a thousand two
hundred and fifty if we're deemed for
travel three travel portal exactly
exactly so for me i made twelve hundred
and fifty dollars just from an eight
minute video that you happen to put out
that i happen to watch take advantage of
so
welcome to the iced coffee hour this is
really cool to have you here and i want
to know how did you get in the whole
credit card game of being able to make
money from credit card companies well i
guess the the first time i ever did
something like this when i lived in the
uk right as a student and at that time
you there was a student bank account
where they would give you an
interest-free overdraft of up to like a
thousand five hundred british pounds
right
and that was 2007. and so savings
accounts were still paying like six
percent so what i did was i overdrew the
student account and i put all the bank's
money in the saving account
and i made six percent off it for like a
year right
and so i was paying zero interest on the
overdraft and getting six bills so that
was my first little getting my feet wet
into the whole what is possible with uh
you know running rings around the banks
and playing them at their own game kind
of thing uh but then it was after i
moved to the us i discovered that uh if
you don't have a credit score
uh life is pretty hard if you try to
rent an apartment or get a cell phone
plan or anything like that so i started
reading the points guy that was kind of
my first intro to it and then i was like
you know developing my credit score and
i was like whoa we can earn points with
this and like fly business class and
stuff like that i've always wanted to do
that so then i started getting into that
aspect of it and then no one was really
doing it on youtube so i was just like
you know what i could i could do this on
youtube so i did and that's basically
how it all started yeah that's so where
did you start what was the first credit
card that you got that you started
getting into churning for me i think it
was the it was the american express gold
card for me and i think at the time did
you get a new one the rose gold like the
metal one this was back in 2000 uh 11 or
12. yeah okay uh yeah 2012
uh is when i got my first amex card and
i think back then it wasn't the 50 000
points i think it was 35 000 points that
i got from amex that was the amex gold
after that i got the
chase sapphire preferred and reserved at
the same time got both of those in the
days you could have two when they first
came out that was the easiest money ever
and i think i used those points a buddy
of mine got married in hawaii and i used
those points to book a plane ticket in
hawaii that's cool yeah so my my first
card was the chase freedom but it it
only came with a little bonus like a
hundred and fifty dollars uh then i had
my second card like the capital one
platinum there's no bonus on it i just
got it because they were sending me junk
mail for it and i was like i can build
my credit score with this so i got it
but then i got the chase sapphire
reserve with the hundred thousand bonus
in 2016 when it just came out
and um yeah i think i used that for like
the w hotel in taiwan and uh
uh yeah a load of other
awesome stuff like yeah so that was my
first huge bonus
tell us about the craziest stuff that
you've done with it crazy stuff give
them give them give everybody a sense of
just like how nuts you could go with
this because i think we're underselling
just how amazing this whole concept is
okay and believe it or not
i think that's a great idea because a
lot of people even in the finance
community don't take advantage of credit
cards we hung out with jeremy last night
uh financial education jeremy huge into
stock investing he told me only has two
credit cards oh really yeah so i think i
think it's definitely good you know to
get people a perspective of what crazy
stuff you're doing the issue though with
jeremy jeremy makes so much money if he
blinks he's losing money when you
consider how valuable his time is worth
so i gotta say there is a sense of
diminishing returns that if you're
making millions of dollars a year i
think it's a middle class game going
yeah going out of your way for an extra
you know a few hundred dollars
yeah you know it starts you start
questioning whether or not it's worth it
but i would say
anyone making under maybe three four
hundred thousand dollars a year this is
one of the easiest side hustles to make
at least a few hundred extra dollars a
month at least at most you'll probably
make an extra what thousand two thousand
a month like depending on how you redeem
these points yeah i mean i don't i don't
go as crazy as some people with it and
also i always travel with my family
which makes it a bit harder to do the
sort of really high class redemptions
like first class um cathay pacific or
something like that yeah emirates but um
i worked out
just on the sort of major trips that
i've done over the last few years it's
23 000 worth of free travel just over
the one just on the ones that i can
remember and there have been numerous
other like weekend trips that i didn't
count but uh yeah 23 000 in the last
like two years or so yeah wow so what
would you recommend for people watching
we'll get right into the the how to
tutorials on this where to start um so
well you got to start by building your
credit score because without a credit
score you're just not going to be
approved for any credit card so normally
i say get a starter card like the
discover it card is a great one to start
with i love that one yeah yeah it's
funny really quick side tangent here
every time i meet somebody they come up
to me like grab guess what guess what
and they everyone whips out their wallet
they pull out the discovery this is my
first credit card my first credit look
at look what i got i'm so proud of them
i'm like oh that's awesome to discover
it not one person has had a single
complaint with them yeah because it's
great you can get approved with it with
basically you know what they call a thin
file like you know not um you know you
can have some of the bad credit score
that they've damaged their credit score
through missed payments but someone who
just has no credit score because they
don't have any information normally they
approve you easy for the discover um it
and it's a great opportunity to have
your first credit card that actually
earns rewards and they do first-year
cashback match so you earn double
cashback in the first year so uh yeah
it's an awesome card definitely
recommend it and then get another card
like don't stop at that you want to get
like
maybe three four cards in your first six
months because the more on-time payments
reported each month the faster your
credit score will grow and you can
literally be at 700 within like
uh three to six months if you do it
right yep um but then at the start your
first five you want to make sure some of
those are chase cards because of the old
524 rule which uh i'm sure you know
about it but like if you
uh have opened more than five credit
cards in the last 24 months you can't
open any chase cards chase won't approve
you for a card so at least maybe one or
two of your first five
should be chase cards if you're starting
now you could get the sapphire preferred
which has a hundred thousand point bonus
you might as well it's free money right
yep um you might wanna get that for
maybe your third card because you wanna
build your credit score a little bit
first uh another good tip is when your
credit score is approaching around 700
uh amex cards actually give quite high
limits yeah that's something i always
recommend because if you can get a card
i remember i had cards with like two
thousand dollar limit that kind of thing
chase freedom
and then i was approaching 700 and i
applied for a hilton card from amex and
it was like boom ten thousand dollar
limit i was like whoa this is this is
cool and then after that happened
i was never denied another card after
that so yeah it's pretty cool basically
you know they see that you've got other
credit cards that are ten thousand
dollars normally they'll easily approve
you for whatever you apply for got it
what about for the people that say that
they don't spend four thousand dollars
in three months so they're afraid that
they're not gonna be able to meet the
minimum spend because that's the one
caveat to some of these cards is they
say in order to be eligible for the
hundred thousand points you have to
spend three four or five thousand
dollars in the first three months
otherwise you don't get it
what i would say is well
one way of doing it is that you could go
for slightly lower tier cards that
you know maybe the bonus isn't as much
but you only have to spend say 500 or a
thousand like particularly people who
are like students or you know who don't
really have a full-time job would
struggle
but you can also look for other ways of
paying um certain charges with the card
that you wouldn't normally you know like
for example you might be able to pay
your student um
tuition with a credit card normally
they'll charge a fee so only pay just
the amount that is needed to get over
the bonus because you don't want that
fee to be too too much but if you say
have to pay a three hundred dollar fee
but you're getting a hundred thousand
points
which is worth one thousand two hundred
fifty dollars through the chase travel
portal uh you minus three hundred you're
still nine hundred and fifty dollars in
profit so paying things like that um or
you could get a credit card just before
you're about to book a big vacation
that's gonna you know cost you a few
thousand uh you can kind of think of it
like that yeah that's what i used to do
is uh when i was renovating properties
i'd purposely delay uh getting a credit
card until i knew i had to make all
these big payments and usually what i'd
i do because i would pay a contractor uh
i would just tell them go and use my
credit card when you're going and paying
for materials that's it and and i would
tell them just go and charge the four
thousand dollars on this anything else
you know i'll just i'll pay you directly
but uh just charge this and uh during
one renovation this was 2016
when the chase sapphire reserve came out
the chase sapphire preferred i think at
the same time i got the amex platinum
and all of those i was just like minimum
spending today minimum spending day
minimalism because i was gonna spend the
money anyway so my thinking was i may as
well just get all of these cards i
didn't want it to go to waste and i
think within those three cards
i was able to get i think i got eighty
thousand for the platinum eighty
thousand points uh a hundred thousand
for the chase sapphire uh reserve i
don't remember what the preferred was it
was either fifty thousand or seventy
five thousand points back then and i
just loaded up and that that to me i
still still have this point
i've not i i've become a point hoarder
but first i want to thank our sponsor
attitude the truth about the betting
aisle at your local store is that most
pillowcases duvets and sheets are
actually made out of cotton and
unfortunately cotton is actually one of
the most damaging fabrics to our planet
and i love trying to protect the planet
anywhere i can i mean we have so many
cool things to appreciate like legos
cats camera equipment and good nights of
sleep alex i think you're the only one
that thinks those are cool except for
the good night of sleep of course and
that is exactly why i actually recently
switched to edited sheets which are made
from 100 organic bamboo that means they
save 500 times more water than cotton
and produce 52 percent less carbon
emissions but seriously guys it's been a
struggle of mine i usually sleep very
hot but ever since i switched to my
edited sheets they help regulate my
temperature like no other sheet i've
ever used and my nights of sleep have
been so much better ever since i started
using etitude so trust me guys you will
absolutely love these sheets and have
the best night of sleep in your life
when you go to edittube.com
iced coffee for 20 off your order and
free shipping and don't forget to use
promo code iced coffee at checkout
remember guys that is attitude as an eco
attitude and don't forget to use the
promo code iced coffee at etitude.com
iced coffee thank you so much attitude
for sponsoring this episode and back to
the
podcast because it's like right now
really where is there to travel
yeah just starting right now yeah
exactly so i think in the next year or
so then i could start using these points
yeah uh but i also want to get to a
million points in my account so i could
physically see
one million points that's cool
yeah yeah then i could spend it yeah i
think right now total i'm at like eight
hundred and fifty nine hundred thousand
yeah that's cool so i just need another
credit card on amex no no this is chase
okay no i think actually if we combine
them i'm over a million points okay
because amex i think is like 500 000
points chase is
eight nine hundred thousand yeah yeah so
yeah nice man that's cool you gotta tell
me where i could go with that oh what i
could do with this there's loads of you
know emirates first class maybe really
wait with chase let me just think about
it let's see which is let's say i have
800 000 points with chase oh you could
do i mean you can go to europe uh
business this is what i do normally i go
to europe every christmas right i got a
business class the new british airways
club suite has a closing door and
that's 50 000 points or at christmas
maybe 60 000 points so you go to europe
business class or first class probably
like
80 000. no one way are you serious yeah
yeah one way 80 000 points one way per
person yeah but don't fly directly to
the uk flight of light if you fly to
spain the taxes and fees are way cheaper
uk hits you with this crazy air text
wait explain explain this i'm yeah this
is great because there's a lot of little
things like this in the credit card game
that catch people out yeah um
basically different countries have
different like rules amount around like
the taxes on the ticket and stuff so if
i book a business class ticket to the uk
which i often do because i just travel
with my family it's most convenient so i
actually absorb the extra cost but um
you might pay 800 in fees so you're
basically paying for an economy class
ticket and then you're like upgrading
with the points to get business class
why is that do they do they tax you on
the retail value of the ticket is that
how it is it's yeah it's just the way i
think they have higher taxes on fuel
like fuel duty and it's just the way
it's done i don't know it's it's a
little bit of a mystery but but if you
put the same ticket going to like
portugal or spain something like that
you will probably pay like 80
in fees
and 50 000 points in business class wow
and then when you're in let's let's say
portugal then what do you did you book
your ticket then yeah if you wanted to
go to uk you would just have to transfer
there and you would get higher taxes on
that really short flight because it's
only a short flight that taxes will be
like 40 or something like that wow it's
a little hack you know
yeah sometimes you've got to really
think out the box because the the
airlines don't want you to redeem for
maximum value they want lower value
right so you've got to kind of play the
game and that's really interesting i had
no idea so you're saying 80 000 points
business class what about like i was
one way would be 50 to 60 thousand okay
europe uh first class maybe he's talking
like eighty to a hundred thousand
depending on the airline one way to go
to europe so yeah so for me and macy to
go that would be four hundred thousand
points yeah
first class round trip for two people so
you could do it wow yeah
random question have you ever been to an
airport lounge yes
all the time i think i sent you a lounge
yeah all the time no yeah all the time
no because yeah like he told me he's
never flown like business or anything
never flown because you haven't flown
businesses never business or first class
but i i would go to um canada to see
family okay and uh every time i go up
there i would purposely go to the
airport a little bit early so i could
hang out in the lounge eat the food and
even by the way if i'm in a rush i would
go into the lounge get the food to go
and then just
eat it and that and that's my meal uh
the one time
we're all flying to utah to visit the
strad man and we get to the lounge there
and they're closed because of uh because
of covid but they're basically just
handing out meals okay so we go there
and i just get enough for all of us
it was it was really nice yeah yeah yeah
but i've been to all the lounges
centurion is amazing uh my favorite was
i think it was dallas
the centurion lounge in dallas if you
you could book a massage there a free
complimentary 15-minute massage
with the credit card for free wow that's
awesome you know i i had the opportunity
to do that in the british airways lounge
one time but
my wife was very slow in packing the
case
and uh we ended up getting to the
airport like just in time for the flight
so we both missed the free massage okay
yeah it was kind of annoying but um
there are some really awesome lounges i
think the best one i've been to is
the club in taipei because i used to go
to taiwan a lot and this was uh
i i had the status with the airline not
through credit cards just because i
built i'd flown so many times that uh
i'd built up like um star alliance
silver and stuff like that and uh yeah
you could go this lounge that was not in
any priority pass or anything yeah and
uh yeah it's a really classy lounge who
goes to this line like do you ever walk
and you're like oh my god that's rod
stewart like
crazy stuff like that i've never seen
anyone famous actually really
no other people have i've seen videos
where like someone bumped into like
wesley snipes or something
oh my god like walking in be like tom
hanks just
chilling in the corner you know eating
his meal
yeah i know every time i walk in because
because now the at least with priority
pass it's everyone has it so priority
pass is really crowded when i first
started going it was 2016. it i felt
like i was bawling like i would walk in
there wasn't that many people i remember
getting a snack for the first time ever
being blown away but now you walk in
there's a line to get in
all the seats are taken the food is half
eaten they've really done the bare
minimum just to maintain priority pass
and now what is it they started charging
if you bring beyond like one guest yeah
the sapphire reserve used to give you
unlimited guests i took like six people
in yeah yeah i worked out it would have
cost like 250 bucks right but then they
limited it to two yeah and i think the
amex platinum is going to start charging
for guests in centurion lounges starting
next year or 2023 i can't remember
i believe it they should allow you one
guess though they should one guest for
free i think that what they want you to
do is get the authorized user card for
your guests do you worry right now that
credit cards are catching on to this
because i feel like
just with with the the explosion of
popularity of personal finance
the credit cards are knowing like hey
too many people are taking advantage of
us right now
we got to downgrade these offers and
make it more expensive no i think
i mean it comes in cycles and actually
some people who are in the industry have
also mentioned this to me as well it's
like it always there's always gonna be
devaluations but then there's always
gonna be new amazing offers coming out
so like back in 2016 we saw the sapphire
reserve hundred thousand yeah and then
for a long time we didn't see any
hundred thousand point offer from chase
and then we had kovid where everything
just shut down the credit cards were
like not really wanting to apply you
know to bring in new people even cutting
limits and stuff and now we're kind of
in a new golden age of huge sign up
bonuses both amex and chase
um
yeah not city i don't know why city
doesn't give any huge bonuses but um mx
and chase are like
you know they're even on their earnings
call their amex talking about yeah we're
really going hard on custom acquisition
in 2021
so
yeah why is that do you think it's
because you're just they want to compete
with chase and chase wants to be with
amex i think yeah i think there's kind
of a battle going on between amex and
chase right now because they are the two
biggest well actually no not the biggest
i think city actually issues more cards
but that's because they have like costco
and american airlines and stuff but um
yeah amex and chase are definitely
battling you know for domination of
of the whole space got it what do you
think the best offers are right now
best offers undoubtedly is going to be
the 100 000 on the sapphire preferred my
hack for that though is that if you want
the sapphire reserve so you get the
lounge axe and everything lounge access
and everything you apply for the
preferred first get the hundred thousand
points and then after a year upgrade to
the reserve
um now when you upgrade are you still
eligible for the sign up bonus on the
reserve yeah so you can you can oh sorry
no so what you can do you can get the
bonus on the preferred so you have that
hundred thousand in your account
once you've upgraded to the reserve if
you've kept those points for a whole
year once you have the reserve the
points are going to be worth more
they're going to be worth 1.5 cents a
point instead of uh 1.25 so you get a
thousand five hundred dollars in value
instead of one thousand two hundred
fifty dollars in value
but first i wanna thank our sponsor
ladder really quick i wanna talk about
the things that fundamentally change the
way that we live these things are called
disruptors disrupters are things such as
youtube smartphones and even internet
banking jack another disruptor is
actually our sponsor today ladder ladder
basically took the life insurance
industry flipped it upside down and
shook out all the inefficiencies before
ladder you actually have to drive across
town fill out a ton of paperwork and
then you still had to wait six to eight
weeks to find out if you were approved
not to mention the countless amounts of
phone calls that you would get from
other agents trying to bundle your life
insurance with car insurance but now we
live in a new era an era where i can buy
dogecoin at the click of a button an era
where i can drink milk straight from the
carton wait a second i didn't know about
that one alex but most importantly an
era where you can get approved all
online for term life insurance for 3
million or less in coverage and if
you're between the ages of 20 and 60 and
you want term life insurance to protect
you and your family choose the latter go
to ladderlife.com
iced coffee today to see if you are
instantly approved that's ladderlife.com
iced coffee you mean
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
you'd have to keep them for a whole year
but um yeah the real reason is so that
like
the reserve is just a better card right
now the stuff i preferred it only gives
you two points per dollar on travel and
dining it's actually not even
it's not that great to be honest but you
wouldn't get the signup bonus on the
reserve with an upgrade so you're
missing out on the sign up bonus but the
santa bonus on the reserve is only 60
000 and you're only allowed one sapphire
at a time so you couldn't get the
preferred first and then apply for the
reserve you'd have to wait four years
and close your preferred
yeah because there's like a one sapphire
rule and stuff so
my kind of hack is if you want the
reserve get the preferred first get the
huge bonus they allow you to upgrade
after one year and then you don't get a
bonus when you upgrade but the points
take on better value got it
yeah see back when i was doing this it
was just unlimited it's you you want the
cards go and take the cards get the
bonuses yeah
yeah that was uh
but you know each period has its own
like hacks and and little things that
yeah yeah it's amazing that you've that
you've turned this into a business what
were you doing before this
so i i came to new york in 2011 and i
was actually i was working at ntd tv
which is uh at that time i don't know if
shaw's is anymore but at that time it
was a non-profit tv station specializing
in broadcasting uncensored news to china
this is gonna be a random story like so
i was born in hong kong so and my major
in college is chinese language
so after i graduated i got this job um
at this non-profit
and
yeah so that was why i came to new york
and through that i became i have a show
um
la why can't jungkook is uh it's a
chinese language show
and it's a very pop it's got like 700
000 subscribers on youtube and uh in
2014 i think by search volume
i was the number three
internet celebrity in taiwan no way it's
like super random right if you search my
name ben hedges on youtube you can find
the channel but yeah super random um but
i was really there because i wanted to
do something and i met my wife there
she was working there so her family had
been persecuted in china uh by the
communist regime there her family you
know her parents
they practiced falun gong which is a
buddhist meditation practice and they
were actually put in forced labor camps
in china
for um for their belief you know and
this practice it's like a peaceful
practice like meditation like it
shouldn't be persecuted in any normal
country you know um but when she turned
18 and they had been released then but
when she turned 18 they basically gave
her all the evidence of what happened to
them and sent her to the us
and uh the u.s was like yeah sure you
can stay you know they gave her asylum
right and her family's all right they're
relatively safe now like it's like not a
super bad situation for them anymore but
um yeah so i met my wife there
and then
i forgot the question
what was the question
how did you turn this into a business
okay yeah yeah so we're getting to that
so like
yeah so after i had you know i'd worked
at this nonprofit for
uh like five years or so and you know
i'd kind of done some good stuff but i
hadn't really earned uh any money you
know because well i was earning money
but it's not like you know it's a
non-profit so you can imagine it's not
like a huge like six-figure job or
anything like that so i was like okay
what shall i do and this is when we're
having our first baby so i was like what
shall i do well why don't i try to do
some youtube stuff because i'd already
done one channel for them and got 700
000 subscribers so me and another guy
we were like okay let's do it on our own
and our first channel was uh generation
tech which is now one of the biggest
star wars channels on youtube it's got i
think it's at 650 000 subs right now
really so yeah and people sometimes
comment they're like they'll find one of
my star wars videos and they'll be like
oh hey credit shifu is super random wow
yeah yeah so if you want to
i do star trek stuff as well i was a
super like star trek nerd when i was in
my early teens so i've kind of milked
that knowledge uh so if you search like
um enterprise uh uss enterprise uh you
know 10 floors or uss enterprise 10
features like all those videos will come
up so um
yeah if you want to brush up wow
no idea okay
so yeah and then at the same time i
started credit shifu and creditship was
originally kind of the side channel
because i was doing like star wars and
star trek content full-time but i was a
little bit tired of it so that was when
i started concentrating more on credit
shift we're to try and get it bigger
and then we started working as a you
know affiliate with um credit card
companies to you know in addition to
adsense we can now have um
sign people up for credit cards and get
commission and uh we can have weeble
they can probably get two free stocks
below with weibull right or public or
public it's worth all the way
[Music]
and if you sign up using the code graham
oh you know what that offer might expire
because it expires july 12th you know
what we want to try to keep it going uh
if the offer is down below you have to
do it before it expires the current
offer expires july 12th so if this if
you're watching this after then the
offer is expired but there might be
another one that the trick is you have
to do it before the offer expires to see
what people's numbers are are you able
to share any numbers with us you know in
regards to to the revenue that these
channels we can yeah um my business
partner he's a little bit more private
than me he doesn't like going super in
depth but uh what i can uh let me think
about it so so we could do you know what
how about this if you could show
what you're making on the credit shifu
channel that's not very much and then
but but then we could i can tell you for
some others
of all the others so that way we don't
exactly know what which channel is which
what i can say is some of our channels
make
as much as the average household income
of the us in one month annual yeah the
average annual household income
how how does how is that channel able to
generate so much where does that come
from that's just from youtube ads that's
just from sheer volume yeah
how many views does this channel get to
be able to do that that's a lot i mean
it's not yeah so it's not a it's my
phone it's not a finance channel yeah so
it has a lower cpm you know like we get
10 dollars i think i'm even up to like
13 now on my cpm but um this channel
it's like can i can i see it yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's look all right so real
time was that great consist consistent
and that's not even you know normally
yeah at the end of the year december is
the best month who and i can show you
guys
i mean i want to see the credit
how much it earns okay so yeah this is
the credit shift but we our views are
way low but
i'd say because you know it's so niche
all right that's the last 28 days all
right still i mean listen sixty one
hundred dollars in 28 days it's not that
good but still but a lot of the income
comes from affiliates oh
i see
here 000 views 48 hours it's not much
it's the views
yeah the views are low but the scene you
know what why is so niche what no no no
my credit card videos pay the most of
anything you know why
because your videos are too short and
you're not putting hold on let me let me
look at this video here we'll analyze
this and by the way we have a full-on
youtube creator academy down below in
the description that uh that i'll do 200
off wow 200 off that teaches you all of
the ins and out but let's see if we can
get your income up okay and this is all
stuff we cover on the program too but so
you got this video the city trifecta
explained 2021 update okay fine uh we'll
just look into this i'm gonna go to
monetization
where's monetization
on is it eight minutes
look at that this is why you're not
making enough money no mid-rolls
only two mid rolls on an 11 minute video
you could do how many would you do
yeah so uh
basically i'll do three up to
10 to 11 minutes
if it's over 13 minutes i will do a
fourth if it's over
17 i'll do a fifth basically one every
three minutes or so is about the sweet
spot because
uh you because
sorry because the ads won't show for
everybody
so sometimes they err on the side of
caution so you could put four ads in
there but people might only see two
that's true so the more ads you put the
more you
the more chances you have that the ad is
going to display
so that is one thing so if you put a
third ad in every video over
eight minutes long your income will
increase about 15 to 20 percent okay
overnight that's a good tip overnight so
you're making an extra through the back
catalog yes so what i would do is sort
through the videos that are the most
viewed every uh over 60 minutes 48 hours
and just put ads in this i wouldn't
bother with all the other ones but my
big thing about this channel in
particular because on our um what's it
called on our other channels like our
star wars channel we can bring in
millions like we'll regularly be doing
maybe 300 000 views over 48 hours or 500
000 years but this one is very low and i
think it's because it's so niche
so i've i've had a plan to kind of
expand into more entertainment based
finance content and i'm probably going
to do it on a second channel
what is your
um
suggestion or recommendation for that
well first one like i said put mid rolls
in these videos so you'll make an extra
20
the other thing before we go into that
is that some of these videos are only
five minutes long
if you could find a way to stretch that
to eight that way you'll get mid rolls
in those videos so
that would
probably
double or triple your income on those
videos by taking it from five to eight
minutes find a way just the last three
minutes to give something else add on
some extra content some bonus content uh
some of these videos like three minutes
don't bother but if it's five you can
get it to eight if it's four
probably just keep it four yeah so uh as
far as starting at another channel
if it's different enough sure
but
if you're going to be talking about
credit cards personal finance you might
be able to just do it on this channel
probably stop recording problem the
problem i've had with this channel is uh
oh yeah stop recording i did this video
a while back uh which metal credit cards
are bulletproof right and i spent so
much time like locating this private
like 80 acres of land to go and shoot on
and calling up friends who have
different types of weapons you know to
do it and it only got 10 000 views and
my feeling is that it's because a lot of
people they come to this channel for
information rather than entertainment
no i just think it was i just think a
niche topic to begin with i think you
could post that on on a huge channel and
just people wouldn't they wouldn't watch
it unless you're like a mr beast where
it's like how many credit cards can you
stack
to stop a bullet yeah yeah then i would
watch that uh i did a video on the main
channel this is my video you did right
yeah with the flamethrower yep did it
get views nope
worst performing video on my my channel
in like years so as some context here i
unboxed the jpmorgan reserve credit card
and this was my most viewed video ever
at the time on my channel by like
tenfold
and i figured okay just unbox this video
they're gonna be retargeting the same
audience what else could i do with the
credit card well
i could burn it with a flamethrower and
so i wanted to test how easy can you
destroy this credit card with like an
axe with a flamethrower with all these
other things i destroyed all my credit
cards and at the end i even called the
customer service lineups like hey my
credit card is damaged i get a new one
they sent me a new one but yeah the
video bombed people hated the video
they're like what is this i didn't
subscribe to this this is stupid some
people didn't get the joke
uh some people were upset at me because
they thought i was being serious when
i'm talking about like i don't like debt
we're gonna burn all my credit cards
they're like graham i just got a credit
card i just got one and now you're
saying it's bad why would you do this
why would you do this to me great it's
like that's a joke but yeah i just don't
think you have to go to such extremes
yeah that
if you're stacking 100 credit cards or
stopping a bullet
maybe that would have a chance or or the
title i would say too like if i read a
title and it says which credit card is
bulletproof i don't really care but if
you oppose it as this is the bulletproof
credit card or this credit card is
bulletproof i may be more likely to
click yeah yeah but that's just me
stopping you got to do stopping a bullet
with credit there you go like yeah
how many credit cards stop a bullet yeah
how many credit cards to stop a bullet
something like that and you just got to
keep stacking credit cards with the
slo-mo cam
you know shooting and and i don't know
like a thousand frames a second or
something like that and you see the
bullet just like ricocheting yeah
you got to do something like that cool
but yeah i don't think it was it
it wasn't the channel
so speaker tips of you want to pivot
into finance you said or
not pivot you want to add finance
related content yeah
yeah go ahead i'm assuming you don't
really talk about this much on your
channel but what do your investments
look like
um so right now uh yeah you'll be
interested in this actually so right now
basically i have used the stock market
to
get
down payments for properties so first i
bought my own house i grew my portfolio
i took one in new york in new york state
yeah upstate new york so i bought my own
house
and then i
my stock market portfolio went down to
like five grand right and then i
invested a load of money during the
pandemic like the march 23rd uh bottom
right pretty much the two weeks either
side of that i was just plowing
thousands and thousands into the market
and i made like a lot of money right so
then i pulled out like i don't know like
35 or something and i went and bought
this piece of land in upstate new york
and i'm gonna do i'm currently working
with a builder and we're gonna build a
luxury airbnb cabin as an investment
property for rich people from new york
city to come and you know have a
vacation in
and so yeah that's and then i've still
got a stock portfolio which is growing
you know and that kind of thing so yeah
but also the cabin it's going to be it's
kind of a cool thing for youtube videos
as well because you can do like you know
you can do people love those videos so
anything involving real estate it's
buying the real estate renovating their
real estate then doing a house tour yeah
that that video did really well actually
i did a land tour right wow how did that
do and yeah i mean i put it on my second
channel which only had like 10 000 subs
and it got over 10 000 views wow uh
which is you know it's a modest figure
but for a channel that's small it's
actually really good you know um
but yeah and you can use tricks like
putting you know
the amount of money i put like 20 i just
spent 28 000 on land it's not even that
much but people just like seeing you
know figure big figures like right stuff
like that so yeah that was cool so we're
like almost about to start building uh
on that piece of land cool and it's
gonna be luxury it's gonna have a hot
tub it's gonna have a sauna it's gonna
have um
yeah all sorts of cool stuff yeah that's
exciting yeah the threshold now
unfortunately on youtube is so high so
it used to be like you spent ten
thousand dollars on a stock
and you would blow it then it became a
hundred thousand but now everybody
investing a hundred thousand dollars in
stock so now it's got to be 500 000 500
seriously jeremy's latest video was 500
000 in a single stock wow
and that's that's now the new the new
tier and pretty soon it's gonna be a
million i did a hundred thousand dollars
with a stock picking monkey
no one cared oh so no one cared no one
watched it how was that threshold
it's up
it's up the video was what's good no no
no the video the video bombs uh because
everyone's like 100k this is what it
like on youtube you work really hard on
something you think is going to be
really good and it's totally bombs it's
the same thing with real estate now too
you have uh ns out there now 20 million
dollar house tour you know so
so you know great oh yeah now there's
that house tour that producer michael
did right you're competing with that
it's like 500 yeah i know no a billion a
500 500 uh 500 million that was the
listing price
but yeah it's getting insane out there
so yeah so i have my monkey portfolio
pulled up here and i'm screen recording
for you nice so so far the monkey
portfolio has made
18.97
since i made that video that was back in
december so i made almost 20
in six months
the number one performing stock
in this account
was ford
up almost 70 percent
i bought ford when it was like seven
dollars it's a new bronco yeah it's
bringing fort up and uh and the electric
mustang and the electric mustang yeah
surprisingly i didn't i'm not a fan of
the electric mustang but people are
buying up the bronco on order yeah all
right so anyway we got invitation homes
up 35 percent
together nice ihs market limited 30
percent blackrock this is a big one 20.
six percent a line technology they do
invisalign
16
republic services this is one i liked a
lot republic services they take out our
trash here they're a big they're waste
management and i believe they also pay a
dividend uh and you got to think trash
collection's not going away that's a
recession-proof business and you and you
look at their chart i mean it's just
consistently
unfortunately we're throwing away more
stuff so i think at some point there's
got to be i think people are going to be
more eco-friendly and conscious of stuff
like that they're going to pivot
and they'll pivot too but uh anyway uh
cerner corporation up three percent the
one i thought was gonna do the best this
one led the way up until february was
tesla now uh only up two percent and
then the losers
netflix is down
and annelle americas which is uh uh
energy i believe in south america okay
that's down seven percent
but overall i got a 20 return with a
monkey
you know i mean it really goes to show
you right now i think uh so many people
are in the stock market today and they
think they are geniuses and we call them
i mean i'm not gonna and they all
started in march last year
so two things um speaking of that
we have the same people back uh uh from
2008 that have only been investing since
like 2009 let's just say and people
before covid were like oh you've only
invested in 2009 about we've only just
seen a bull market and then now we're
seeing the same people you've only been
investing since march so it's always
that next thing but we call them i i'm
not going to
paint names
i'm not going to mention any names here
but we call them uh cheerleaders yeah
because really there's there's zero due
diligence there's zero analysis that's
going on stock it's just
guys we gotta stay strong we gotta keep
buying and meanwhile it's like tanking
tank guys we gotta buy more this is our
chance we're gonna make a lot of money
right it's not even just me it's it's
everything and it's insane and it's just
the lower the price goes the more hypey
they get and there's again there's no
analysis yeah nothing it's just
it's gonna go to the moon we gotta keep
buying it we gotta keep holding it they
all have a name for like their followers
and it's just we're gonna buy this stock
we're gonna keep buying and we'll see
what happens on that but it's it's a
scary time where like
that that's the new breed of investor
and i'm sure warren buffett would say
the same thing about like wall street
bets like it's a scary time for this new
investors investing on robin hood
commission free trade so i you know
maybe maybe you now we're the we're the
old people yeah i think with wall street
bets it's like
it's cool to read it and i've invented i
made a good money on amc you know i but
i only do it with small amounts of them
like i put in like a thousand back in
january and i took out like three or
four thousand
paper hands
you paper hands
maybe you should cut that because
everyone's gonna hate me but yeah i
can't believe it yeah are you still
holding no no i i don't own any amc but
and that's the thing that is shocking to
me that that especially when someone
gets in and they get out with a profit
and they've made a 500 a thousand
percent return on your money you know
it's a problem when people like you
paper-handed yeah what's
it's like shameful that you made a
thousand percent return on your money
like that's like you you did everyone
dirty it's insane it's like the purpose
of investing is to make money you should
be commending these people who have sold
some of these things and it's like no
it's like it's backwards it doesn't make
any sense to me so we'll see if this
sticks around long term i don't think it
will but
yeah i don't think i can i think like
gamestop was probably the
sort of biggest example of it i suspect
that could be the biggest example of it
we're ever going to see because i don't
think amc well i don't know it probably
will now but i don't think it's going to
go that much higher because i feel like
the the wall street people are kind of
doing some stuff behind the scenes i'm
going to tell you i personally again we
could look back at this and maybe i
could be wrong i personally don't think
it's going to go much above where it is
maybe just by like 10 bucks or something
like that i would be shocked to see it
in a hundred and that's been the
threshold my thinking is that uh and i
think this is just human psychology uh
people only have a certain amount of
patience to hold this stock
and i think
if it's gonna hold out like this for
much longer people are gonna say it's
not doing anything let me go and move it
into uh build a bear or like we know
something else instead i'm in that too
and it's uh just a little i think it's
slowly gonna just
let some of the air out of the uh
balloon yeah that's what i think is
gonna happen i think if in a perf in
under perfect conditions
maybe this thing but i just think
there's not enough people out there
going to buy it and hold it and
and and now i bet there's going to be
people oh graham's
a shill it's a wall street shell because
people call me a shell for talking about
this stuff because i'm like being honest
i i just i don't see it and i i know we
make jokes about jack being paper-handed
but he made 1300 or whatever
jack turned a hundred dollars into 13
thousand dollars
and he sold and it's
dogecoin that's great i've been telling
him to sell that that thing hit 30 cents
as like sell sell sell 50 cents sell
i've just been sell the whole the whole
time
and uh jack happened to sell at the
perfect time right before snl oh before
us
right before snl i wish i could have
sold like i i was holding it that day
and i was like shall i sell before shall
i sell after and i i knew it could go
either way you know and then i was
watching it and elon wasn't really doing
anything you know and i was like all
right i'll try and sell and then robin
hood which i was holding i don't
normally use robin hood but for dogecoin
i was using it and it was like not
allowing you to sell and i ended up
selling at like 50. yeah so the problem
with that um
my theory with that is that right you
know robin hood is really just it
everything is really done within that
platform
so when they have so many sell orders
coming in at the same time but they
don't have enough the equivalent of buy
orders they can't fill those orders so
either what happens is that you have
people who are like buyers let's say at
20 cents then you have all these orders
filling in at 20 cents from people who
are willing to sell at any price the
buyers are willing to pay like 10 or 20
cents it would crash the price just on
robinhood whereas meanwhile all the
other platforms would be a neutral price
so they had to maintain the price in
line with everybody else but
it's just a wild thing but yeah jack
jack got in really well on that one and
i i i'm proud of him
for and i didn't think he was gonna do
it because he was like i'm diamond hands
and diamond hands but you know what i
mean when there's 13 000 on the line all
profit i think he made the smart move
that's uh yeah that's similar to well
nowhere near as good but my best result
has been with was with tesla i got a
thousand percent yeah return on that
same yeah you did right yeah i think a
lot of us did uh meet kevin i went to
his
seminar in new york two years ago and he
was talking about buying it at like 180
yep pre-split price you know
i think i bought it i i still have two
shares of it because i just sold i sold
most of it most of that was my 28 000
land purchase was from tesla
but um
yeah i've got like two shares now and my
cost basis is forty dollars yeah and the
stock price is six hundred dollars so
yeah it's pretty cool
that's about the same as me um
bought tesla back when it was
240 250
free split
um so would that be like 50 bucks around
there around 50
unfortunately i sold half when it hit
900. and for
a brief moment i was a genius because it
hit 900 i sold and the next day it
started dropping and it dropped all the
way down to like 400. and i was like
i made out like a bandit
but then it kept going up
and i just
i i missed that opportunity to buy but i
did i did put in a big chunk
right before they announced the split oh
and you made a nice little gain yeah and
i still hold all of it so my my theory
is now i'm not going to sell something
unless i need the money because every
time i've sold something when i didn't
need the money because i think the price
is going up you know too high even if it
drops in the short term that the
psychology the fact that i sold
just makes me less likely to buy yeah um
so i just hold it's the whole uh
intelligent investor thing anyway isn't
it goes back to all that it's like just
buy and hold can sometimes be far better
and also if you sell under a year of
holding you have to pay higher taxes
yeah you know what would be really fun
to do right now you should review alex's
wallet oh yeah and let us know what you
think about it and you know what even
more exciting we're gonna make this
eclipse channel exclusive whoa yeah so
we have a link to the clips channel down
below in the description it's brand new
go ahead and subscribe to that this is
only going to be available on there so
again it's in the description and uh
let's get into it so i heard of a amex
platinum hack i'm not sure if i heard
this from you i don't think so i think
it was another random channel that
popped up
so uh last year i think it was around
like august september
uh i realized with my mx platinum that
like i am just not using it at all i
don't use it to charge anything because
the amex gold is better for points i'm
not traveling there's no point in me
spending 550 a year so this guy i saw i
saw his video says you could get
uh 50 000 points for free on the amex
platinum
just by saying you're gonna cancel the
card so i went through his youtube video
yeah i did so i went through his youtube
video perfectly so what you have to do
he wanted me to uh uh go to the go
online and talk to one of their like the
little chat people
and i said hey i'd like to cancel the
card they then respond back with
but let me tell you all the amazing
things about this card that maybe you
didn't know about to make it worth it
they run through all of that
yeah i know i still want to cancel the
card oh what about the all this other
stuff no i still want to cancel the card
oh so uh if i'm understanding you
correctly you want to cancel the card
i'm like yeah i'll cancel the card it's
just not worth it to me and then you
have to say is there anything that you
could do
to retain my business because i think if
you just say like you just cancel
they'll be all right i'll cancel but you
have to say is there anything that you
could do for me
let me let me get back to you let me get
and then they come back to you like five
minutes later we're able to offer you at
least it seems like this is the the
go-to we're able to offer you 50 000
points if you don't cancel and just keep
the card an extra year so i figured
uh you know 50 000 points i could
probably get that 700
you know 800 worth of value transferring
it to an airline so i would pay 550 for
eight hundred dollars
fair so that's what i did i'm keeping
the card yep
and uh and uh i i'm probably just gonna
cancel the card uh it's september yeah
after yeah i think this year september
it'll be a year retention offers are a
great way but wait a minute how do you
get into the centurion lounge
i don't mean barely travel oh yeah yeah
i barely travel i mean
but yeah retention offers a great i did
a retention offer on the old spg card
which then turned into the marriott bon
voyage yeah i got that card too you got
the card too right and i got 25
no 30 000 points i forget where i used i
think it was uh gosh i used it many
years ago but yeah spg used to be like
the best you know hotel system and it's
a little bit devalued now it's part of
marriott but yeah i got a retention
offer for 7 000 spg points which is
worth 21 000 marriott points yeah just
by calling up and saying hey i'm
thinking of cancelling and just directly
saying are there any retention offers
available because literally depending on
how good a customer you are
they will have certain set offers that
they can offer you so they'll go off and
do something on the computer and then
come back so i don't know maybe if you
let them do the whole spiel first it
might do something i don't know i uh the
way i've always done it is just phoning
up i'm just very direct i say you know
are there any retention offers you could
offer me you know
and that's it yeah
yeah i know i i gave him the whole the
whole run around on that that's cool but
yeah
so i might do that with my child schwab
plant them because the uh the points are
going to devalue wait a second
that's what i should get the char
platinum you could but the points are
devaluing they're going down from 1.25
percent
1.25 cents per point to 1.1
99
certain it's happening september but
isn't that still better than me paying
550 a year for the normal platinum yeah
you could actually uh cancel your
platinum and then apply for the charge
to our planet because it's considered a
separate product so you can still get
the bonus and i could still go to the
lounge and you could still go to the
lounge now for the charles schwab
platinum
it's it's free right or what's what's
the dollar amount that you have to if
you have uh well the the fee is 550 yes
but if you have over 250 000 with schwab
yeah you get 100 off and if you have
over 1 million with schwab you get 200
off is there anything above a million or
is this 200 off um the the highest is
200
i thought it was free i thought it was
like for every
million you have with them it's like you
know 100 off or something like that
that would be great yeah you could be
paying 350.
do you know if there's a way that if you
could call them and be like hey
good customer swap can you just give me
this card do you know if there's a win i
don't think so
yeah i don't think so dave hansen was
asking about this too really yeah
yeah gosh are there any do you know of
any offers for like uh like like you
know big big spenders big ballers out
there who have like you know cash in the
bank yeah like bram and jack yeah they
spend so much money what can you know i
can actually research this and come back
to you a really good offer in the past
used to be the alliant credit union uh
card yeah my friend he got this and
basically it gives unlimited 2.5
cashback on everything and then for the
first year it was three percent and it
was it was specifically for high
spenders so a friend of mine he got it
and he went and bought a red cinema
camera that's like 50 grand or something
and he got three percent cash back on it
so but actually they've been or you can
just use the credit card yeah if you've
got the character credit card it's
probably right it's pretty good for yeah
um
you should be getting the centurion soon
right maybe getting an invite
i wouldn't do it you wouldn't do it i
wouldn't do it
so it's a so for those that aren't aware
yeah actually i i watched your video on
this did you made a video on the yeah
the new one what is it it's a 10 000
initiation
right
and then every year it was
five grand a year after that so like up
front you're spending fifteen thousand
dollars up front to get the amex black
card now i was thinking okay if it's
five grand
i can make a video on it and like worst
case i'll make the money back it'll be
break even for the first year i can't
justify 50 like i know 15.
best case scenario the video makes like
seven grand best case and that's if the
video gets like 500 000 views does well
i'm not gonna spend seven thousand on a
card that i'm not going to use that that
isn't that good
but it's not yeah it's i mean
i don't know
it's just not a good card uh the one
thing that i was thinking uh they offer
you a free equinox or what does it do
200 and something dollars off your
equinox membership yeah it only adds up
to like a thousand or two a year right
it's like yeah it's like twenty four
hundred dollars a year
not worth it i don't go to equinox you
get access to the private suite at lax
you know about that oh yeah i do i i how
often do i travel with lax yeah exactly
yeah so it's really just something you
pull out to be like i wasted a whole
bunch of money on this card
yeah it's really bad they may have a new
one coming out we don't know but above
platinum they should talk a bit yeah
they should people think it's going to
be called the optio card because that
was the rank below centurion the roman
army i really don't think it's going to
be called that but uh that's what people
are kind of calling and it would have a
fee of a thousand five hundred in theory
so if i if that comes out i'm gonna get
it yeah you know what i think they
should make more high-end credit cards
because right now the chase sapphire and
the amex platinum i think are pretty
much like the same level they're
basically equal
but there's nothing else between that
and like the jp morgan reserve or the
amex intern this there's not it's it's
either you have 20 million bucks or you
spend 550 dollars i mean that that's it
there's nothing i would like to see more
luxury high tiered credit cards
um yeah because yeah people who are
earning maybe 50 grand a year could
still have the platinum and get value
out of it whereas the centurion you need
to be earning like at least a few
million really to get value and you need
to have a lifestyle that's suited to it
i know it's almost like the carrot card
like i feel like i know it's geared
towards influencers but i feel like the
people who it really targets are who
you're talking about
yeah no i but care it's more like social
media i'm talking about like people
probably making
500 000 to 3 million a year okay who are
probably like a little bit more on point
with their money they're less about the
flex but they still want you know
something that stands out yeah from the
crowd the annual fee that's about a
thousand five hundred would make it
prohibitively expensive for people who
are like under 100 i think 2500 a year
oh i think that that's the sweet spot if
it was that i would question whether it
would be worth it it would have to have
for me yeah it would have to have really
good benefits yeah because i have to get
that back i bet they would be able to do
it with like a 500 a year door dash
credits a thousand dollar travel credit
they would find ways
yeah but yeah if they came out with
credit card 2500 a year or less 1025
sweet spot i just make it nice
you know yeah you got you gotta like you
know what like making a silver credit
card or like have it yeah have it made
out of like a metal something like that
yeah
it's got to be something cool
it's got to be effective and it's still
got to be a flex it's got to be a flex
yeah make it oh you know what how did it
be a bottle opener
self-defense yeah
bulletproof yeah
yeah
i can show you what i've got
in my wallet
all right let's see what you got now
yeah this is so this is my travel wallet
um
so there's a little bit alex that's the
size you need this is the traveler
wallet it's too bad you didn't pull out
a ridge wallet this would be the perfect
if we could do a rich sponsorship please
man 28 credit shifter.com forward slash
shop oh wow whatever
all right i'll show you what i got so i
got actually with me i've got the amex
rose gold which kind of looks pink
i see it
yep and i've got the uh
charles schwab mx platinum okay which
that's just for getting into the
centurion lounge which i uh i stopped at
phoenix for like four hours so i spent
three hours in the centurion lounge on
the way
uh i've got the chase sapphire reserve
this is kind of like a workhorse car
that i use for like a lot of stuff
because
i i don't know i just put stuff on this
because i'm used to monitoring it and
paying it off like it's in my chase
actually right so it's like open up my
chase it's right there um
this
is the chase freedom flex i've got this
basically for gas because right now it's
five percent on gas this quarter next
quarter it changes but that's what i'm
using
uh i've got
hilton um because we stayed in the
oceana santa monica which is a hilton
property so this was for all the meals
and uh the ridiculously overpriced
restaurant at that property
you get extra like 12 points or
something per dollar i don't know forget
what it is
uh we got the old ink good preferred
cool uh i got 80 000 on this nice
yeah it's kind of funny when i i got
denied for this because i i typed in my
own social security number wrong uh the
first attempt oh wow okay they sorted it
out for me and yeah but yeah that's just
for business expenses but actually i
haven't used it at all because
yeah whatever and then
we have a
let me see where is it
where i cut this
fast forward or something there we go
we have the uh charles schwab debit card
which is really useful for
uh waiving atm fees so if you go to like
some sketchy ac atm that's like three
dollar fee i think i went to um the one
in the casino yesterday charged 9.99 wow
wow i hope it weighs the fee it should
waive anything so what's the what's the
deal with that one i'm not familiar with
that uh the money just comes out of your
charles schwab either your child show up
checking or your child schwab brokerage
account so whenever i want cash recently
i've just been uh spending my amc money
um so i yeah i've just been using that
to waive fees i mean i hardly ever use
cash so i'll just take it out of my
schwab and then maybe i'll transfer some
more money over there if i want but yeah
um it's really great to and it's kind of
unlimited it's a benefit i don't know
they might they might limit it in the
future but right now it's like any atm
fees they'll just refund so what if
you set up your own atm company and
charge like a 20 fee
and then pull money out of your own atm
and then i think there might be a team
that looks for abuse like what if we set
up yeah we could set up an atm we'll
split the profit with you you just keep
withdrawing 20 at a time with a 20 fee
and just double our money yeah i don't
know i i think it would be how long that
could be maintained for rather than how
much you could same the same way every
day in withdrawal
every 20 minutes
yeah nothing suspicious about that yeah
yeah so that's my yeah that's my travel
wallet yes buddy speaking of the hilton
card uh so this is what i wanted to tell
you the uh the other day we went to
resorts world las vegas
and i'm i'm going up there and i wanted
to deposit a hundred dollars on their
app just for the vlog the purpose was uh
we had a buddy
who wanted to load his account with 10
grand virtually and they were charging
him a 2.9
fee so it was 290 dollars as a fee just
to load his account to be able to gamble
so i said you know i'll do a hundred
dollars and just just review it and then
i'm talking to the guy and he's saying
well if you deposit a hundred dollars
there's a ten dollar bonus a free play
that you could get
and i said well is there something if i
deposit more because yeah you could
deposit a thousand dollars and we'll
give you a hundred and fifty dollars
and i'm looking at me like yeah i'm
gonna do the thousand i had no intention
of gambling more than like you know
honestly 100 200 bucks max so i load a
thousand dollars in the account and i
said is there anything stopping me from
just going and immediately cashing out
after this
he's like
oh well i get i i guess not it's like
like a short story in his face like what
why would you do that
uh but yeah so i deposited a thousand
dollars in the app so you have to do
this in person by the way you can't just
make an account anywhere and like
deposit money you have to do it in
person because they verify your id it's
a lengthy process you got to put in your
like your driver's license
there's someone there to verify it your
social security number link your bank
account with plaid like there's a big
thing
but i did all of that and sure enough
within 15 minutes a hundred and fifty
dollars shows up in my account they also
on the first transaction they waived the
2.9 percent fee wow so he got a thousand
dollars in there they waved to the fee
and they gave me a hundred and fifty
dollars uh that's just totally free that
i could cash out of and then what if you
want the thousand back so here's the
thing okay so i'm getting yeah great
question so what i did to start is i put
all 150 on one hand to backroad because
my thought was this is a free hand i'm
either doubling it and walking away or
i'm walking away even not losing any
money
put the 150 in bagra the whole
experience by the way was super glitchy
they were promoting themselves as this
casino that's like cashless like you
could just go up with your phone they do
this
half the half the stuff doesn't work
it's straight up oh i i was trying to
get it and they're like totally clueless
on what to do they had no idea it's like
they had never seen this thing before
nobody's using it okay and it took like
three or four minutes just to load my
account and i tried multiple times like
tried to scan it it's just terrible
experience but anyway so we did we did
put a hundred and fifty dollars on one
handed back right but banker
i won wow
yeah yeah that's nice so got 300 bucks
um
and then i went to try to cash out now
they said originally
there was the option to take the money
from your account and do an ach transfer
back to your normal bank account they
said it was going to take anywhere from
three to seven days but they charged you
a fee of two dollars to do it
the problem is that
there's no option on the app to withdraw
your money there's no option they said
there was an option to take your money
out
i did not find a single thing i even
went up to the cashier at the register
and i said how can i move my money from
here back to my bank account so i don't
walk out with like a thousand dollars in
cash
i
don't know like that's my manager and
then the manager no idea but you can
still get cash yes so you have to tell
them i want to cash out
entirely from my from the app they go
and they type in your information they
go and give you cash
but there is no way to cash out of this
thing and i think they they imagine that
people are going to load their account
with the money and then be like well i
have to either go back to cash out or
now that i'm here i may as well just
gamble it i think it's like the
equivalent of gift cards so yeah you
have to do this in person i have a
feeling uh p so many people are going to
start exploiting that they got they got
to stop that soon or it might be like
the carrot thing there's only one person
like you now everyone else will do it
believe it or not i so i posted this on
instagram yesterday did some people do
it we got stops like four times walking
out of the casino yesterday uh one of
those people said he saw my instagram
story and was going to the casino to do
that and he happened to run into me as i
was walking out of the casino i saw it
last night yeah and i was thinking shall
i go over there and yeah you know what
150 bucks is not
quite enough for me to be bothered to go
you got to go to the casino
once just to experience it yeah i
honestly i'll be honest the casino was
crazy
it was bad uh i think i'm not a huge fan
of big crowds and there's a lot of
people there so that automatically
that's not a fault of the casino though
but but the actual experience of the
casino i wasn't a fan the app was
extremely glitchy
i prefer the win if you're gonna go
anywhere the win and encore just superb
so i wouldn't go back it's it's you go
there once you experience it you never
go back again so that was my experience
with that but okay a lot of people today
are messaging me on instagram saying
i did this wow and they're tagging me in
it look at me graham i got they're
showing me their account with the money
in it so a lot of people are doing this
maybe they won't let you back we got to
think what would jack ask right now yeah
so jack would ask you to review his
tinder profile yeah
are you good with the ladies well i'm
married oh how long uh
when did we get married
2014 i think
how old are you i'm 35. yeah so imagine
i'm a
22 year old good looking guy i see you
you've been trying
spike ball
um
you know what what's the best dating
advice that you could give me
hypothetically or what's what's the best
pickup line yeah
i you know personally i don't really do
pick up lines because i like i think you
just gotta you just gotta meet someone
and
strike up a rapport with them and then
it becomes natural you know i like dan
blizzarian's advice actually that he
gave on london reel when he was
interviewed by them he said you just got
to have the confidence and go and talk
to loads of ladies
and
just
assume that you're going to get rejected
it doesn't matter because it's a numbers
game if you talk to enough of them
uh
eventually you know and and as you get
good at it they're gonna feel this guy
is so confident that he's really not um
you know uh what's the word he's not
intimidated and then they actually
respect that you know they're like the
women respect confidence and a guy who
can just talk naturally yeah to someone
there's no tricks you know what i mean
it's not like
darn yeah we want to trade
the magic
lines we wanna like all you got to do is
say this hey yeah is heaven missing an
angel because you know because she is
saying that excuse me
what is it did you are you hurt because
you just fell from heaven
[Music]
you know what i would love to see jack
do it and have it actually work
i bet i bet if you don't if you actually
go and do that i bet if you if you say
it the right way it'll work
i feel like you get slapped but no why
would you get slapped that's a
compliment i guess it depends on the
situation it depends on could come
across
these pickup lines are kind of crazy
yeah yeah yeah i think didn't you try to
set him up on a blind date though yeah
and didn't go too well or no no no i
watched that i saw the video
no uh abby was fantastic we really liked
abby a lot but i think uh it just
you know you never know yeah physically
just never yeah logistically it wasn't
there and uh you know
just not
yeah my experience like dating apps as
well it's like yeah you might meet
someone on there but i feel like you're
more likely to meet someone in real life
the old-fashioned way you know just like
i believe in kind of destiny in a way as
well just like you might be introduced
through a mutual friend what's your take
on dave ramsey oh dave i did a video
recently about it yeah it's funny um
you know i i think he's for a certain
type of person i have some friends who
really follow him and they're like oh
yeah we don't want any credit cards we
don't even really want a credit score
i'm like well what about if you get a
mortgage and we're like oh we'll have
someone like yeah the manual underwrite
that doesn't exist i mean i'm sure it
does but gosh why if you have a choice
between just getting a credit card or
going through manual underwriting i mean
oh geez my feeling is like i want to
play the banks at their own game i don't
want like some people if they follow
dave ramsey they're like okay we'll just
resist the banks all together my feeling
is like yeah play their game but
outplay them at their own game sure
that's that's kind of my take on it yeah
i agree with that i think i i think you
guys would agree i mean i think the
advice that he gives when you're first
getting into personal finance especially
if you have like a little bit of debt
best advice he could give you yeah but
there comes a time where you outgrow him
and
you know i think if you're paying yeah
if you're paying off debt
go to damn's dave ramsey but once you're
done yeah i don't know i feel like dave
dave is good for fifty percent of the
population yes yeah i would say what we
talk about is good for
10 to 20.
and then there's that middle ground
where they could probably they those the
middle ground is probably a transition
they start with dave they end somewhere
else but yeah i would say dave on a
broad scale probably best for the
majority of people yeah
yeah so ben thank you so much for coming
all the way out here i really appreciate
it it's awesome man thanks for having me
and with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
we're going to link to everything you
have down below in the description you
have wallets for sale we do so you know
what i'll link to that credit shifter
wallets
get em at
creditshifter.com yeah and also down
below in the description you can get
your free stock worth all the way up to
seventy dollars seventy dollars seventy
dollars and they also don't route your
order flow unlike other brokerages out
there which is unfortunately the name
huh we can't say who it is but they do
it public does not and also i'm posting
all of my own stock trades on there so
if you want to see what i'm buying just
follow me on public dot com slash gram
use code gram get your free stock i'm
going to immediately do that and get my
free stock with 170 it's basically go to
the casino getting your free 150 except
you could do it right now for the
comfort of your own home it's worth all
the way up to 70
so thanks so much guys i really
appreciate it and until next time